الله الذي لا اله الا هو الرحمن الرحيم
مالك قدوس السلام المؤين المحين العزيز
الجبار المتكبر الخالق البارئ المصير الفب
القهار الوحاب الرزاق الفتاق والعلي الحض
الباط الخاص
الرافع ع السمير البق الحكم اللطيف الخبير
حب العظي الفور الشكور العلي الكبير حقظ
السيف عيب الدليل الكريم العقيب دييب
الواسع الحكم ودود الدييب البعيث الشهيد
محق الوكيل القوي المتين الولي الحمد الح
المخلق
منخير الواجد الجد الواق الصمد القاد الدر
المقد المخر الاول الاخر ظاهر الباطن
الو والمتقي
والف والم والمم والجلال والاكرام المحس
الزم والغاني المجم وال ا ناقع الور الهيا
ديع الباقي اوال الفيم البور
الك ف شيء وهو
البص اللهم صلي قال الصلاه على اسعب
مخلوقاتك
سيدنا محمد
وسمع
مماتك
ومدا كلمه اك كلما ذكرك تكون